over the years i've always taken the
position that basically nothing need be
done
that
you know there is a uh
i'm not a i'm an agnostic religiously
which is say what can you show me
position
but i've always had the feeling that the
universe was put together in such a way
that it would work out all right
in the end
and have from my days
in the berkeley underground
i've
got a very healthy suspicion of leaders
and plans i mean i'm even more caustic
on the subject of political leaders than
i am on the subject of gurus
but nevertheless well this is a subject
which is very hot in our household which
is is the world getting better or is it
getting worse
and is there anything
that we personally
can do about it
and because it's always been my feeling
that it was all taken care of from
hyperspace
and that it would all make sense in the
end when the historical culmination
became visible to all the participants
i've taken the position that
the real political frontier is ourselves
reconstructing our attitudes uh molding
ourselves to be as caring loving and
conscious as we wish
that our leaders would be
nevertheless uh the culture crisis is
intensifying there's plenty of evidence
that things are
getting worse
in a hurry things like what i talked
about last night the burning of the
amazon the rise of the greenhouse effect
so forth and so on
so
it seems to me there are political
options there are
positions that need to be taken that are
not being taken
there are answers
even if
you are not a transcendentalist even if
you don't believe in the inevitable
working out of human history to the
satisfaction of everyone
and uh
when you begin to talk politics you
inevitably brush
the subject of responsibility
and permission
what kind of responsibilities
do we have to each other to the planet
to the future
what kind of permission
can we take from each other
from the planet
what is to be done and what can be done
and i wanted to
talk a little bit about this this
morning some ideas that we'll throw out
basically to get your feedback it's a
little different take
than
the psychedelic ranger sort of position
that you may be used to hearing
the psychedelic movement of the 1960s
uh
had no political
agenda really
i mean tim leary's agenda was turn on
tune in drop out
and the war
was a side issue where the new left made
common cause with the psychedelic people
and the war was eventually ended but the
psychedelic movement went nowhere except
underground and i think this was largely
because they disdain
to set
real-world political goals that
non-psychedelic people and let's face it
probably 95
at least if the human race is
non-psychedelic
non-psychedelic people
needed an agenda to relate to
and even in my own life i
have a kind of a tendency not to want to
dabble in politics not to want to
propose concrete solutions because they
are easily subverted easily attacked
they
create factionalism
which i think is a bad thing but
nevertheless i think there are
arenas and theaters of political action
that are not being articulated that we
could take more seriously and i want to
talk about a few of them fairly briefly
and then hopefully we can have a
dialogue about this
the first question being is it necessary
at all
to have a political agenda are we not
perhaps becoming frightened by the
intensifying of the historical crisis to
the point where we doubt our own
previous point of view
or
if you think it is necessary to have a
political agenda then what sort of
agenda should it be and i want to start
with the most immediate
and practical possibilities first and
then move towards some of the more
long-range
and globally
impactful possibilities
last night we talked about the
destruction of the rain forest in brazil
a very obvious political first step to
halting what is going on with the
destruction of nature in the third world
is
to get the international lending
community
to
exercise a degree of moral
responsibility
in other words it's a shocking notion to
suggest that the international monetary
fund
only support ecologically sound
projects
and yet it seems to me obvious that this
should be done
it isn't the brazilian government that
should be blamed for
the clearing of the amazon
or the land-hungry brazilian peasantry
it's the imf and the world bank because
they pay for it they make the
multi-billion dollar loans that make
this kind of thing possible
banks are amenable to political pressure
if their dirty laundry were shrillly
laundered in public
they would have a public relations
problem that would force them to rethink
what they are doing
there was an article in the new york
times about five days ago about how
world capitalism big capitalism is
finally actually alarmed by the
greenhouse effect because it's hitting
their investment
we live in the world but there are
agencies that think they own it
and uh when they see that their
investment is threatened and that's how
they analyze it these people don't love
wild animals and
climaxed rainforests they love money
and when they see their investment
threatened i would think they could be
pressured to
revise their loan policies
another step that it seems to me
lies directly ahead of us in the future
that i do not understand why it isn't
more discussed and can only conclude
somewhat light-heartedly because i don't
like being a paranoid that there must be
a conspiracy
against what i am about to propose a
conspiracy run by governments and that
is
the international boycott
is potentially a tremendous tool for
problem solving
but to date it has been so
gutted and watered down that it becomes
no more than a gesture the world today
is a global whole
it is very tightly
webbed together and spun into itself one
part into another
let's take the case of south africa
which i am hope with this crowd is a
fairly uncontroversial case
everyone is waving their arms saying
something must be done about south
africa it's a barbarian situation it's
intolerable
and the notion of a boycott as presently
practiced is that general motors will
take 18 months to cut its investment
there in half
and then this is hailed as a great step
forward
but in fact
the
uh the financial and political machinery
is in place to make life hell
for the government of south africa if
you are serious about changing the
policies of government you don't
threaten to withdraw your investment
over four years
you say
look
there will be no mail. there will be no
telephones there will be no
international banking transactions
you're through we're just pulling the
plug on this scene
and i guarantee you you would get action
the there is no reason why mail should
be delivered to that country there is no
reason why telephone service should be
maintained with these people and it is
inexcusable to loan them a single dime
obviously and you know choose
whatever problems scattered around the
world irk you particularly northern
ireland
israel
iran iraq war
uh
territorial encroachments going on in
africa if these people were just told no
money no phone no mail no trade nothing
it would uh and i believe that this
isn't done because every government
fears that if the machinery to apply
tools like this were in place it might
eventually be their turn
and no country wants to face that
because that's serious you can't go
forward they're just calling in the
chips when they do that so this is
something which rather than feeling
totally powerless we should all advocate
the tremendous strengthening of the
notion of international boycotts this is
very useful not a shot needs to be fired
and it goes without saying weaponry
should be withheld from these people
spare parts technology
engineers these south africans should
not be sending their people to our
engineering schools in fact they
shouldn't their passports shouldn't be
honored anywhere they should be invited
to go home and live in their wonderful
society if they think it's so great
and they can forget about phoning new
york or getting mail from new york and
paris but you're suggesting this uh
originally here as an ecological as a
technique for leaning on the situations
that are laying waste
i think it can be applied to like the
brazilian situation the south african
situation
wars wars cannot be fought without an
influx of capital materiel and
information
it's obviously something that people
would favor that governments would
oppose and so we've i've never heard any
politician of any stripe from gorbachev
to bush suggests that the strengthening
of the machinery of international
boycotts would be an obvious first step
toward putting this planet on a
reasonable course
[Music]
you